prévenus par olten so lundi pluie alors
cette semaine je choisis un père qu'à
2010 confiné où les gens décident de
pratiquer ou de ne pas pratiquer la
distanciation social de façon
sécuritaire pour vous parler d'un sujet
qui malheureusement a été inspiré par
rapport aux commentaires que l'on voit
en ligne en lien avec les politiques de
confinement et de déconfinement pourquoi
je sais que dernièrement ont aussi
beaucoup de bonnes nouvelles de
politique de déconfinement ses
dirigeants ont pour accéder à certains
services vont pouvoir faire des bulles
social s'ils le désirent pour pouvoir
aussi accéder à des parcs et des ces
packs qui aurait fermé pendant des mois
et pour beaucoup de gens de la grande
région de montréal c'est une nouvelle
extraordinaire puisque on manque d
espace pour pouvoir faire des activités
à distanciation social sécuritaire mais
cependant c'est pas une très bonne
nouvelle pour certains membres des
communautés qui sont proches de ces
lieux qu'elle tels que les partis les
sépaq et là je veux appuyer tout cas la
communauté de kermesse un paquet qui l a
décidé d'appliquer une politique de
confinement très sévère très serré c'est
à dire de ne pas accès à sa communauté à
quiconque ne vient pas de la communauté
mais cela veut dire qu'avec l'ouverture
du parc d'oka une plus grande banque de
personnes qui viennent de montréal de
tourisme montréalais et des régions
avant taux vont accéder à la communauté
et vont accéder aussi à la communauté
d'aucuns qui est voisine de qena
s'attaquer ainsi qu'au parc et donc
augmenter les chances qu'une vague de
covile deviennent sur les communautés
marocaine à cet acquis
c'est extrêmement difficile de ne pas
être touché par le lot de commentaires
extrêmement raciste extrêmement
désobligeants que l'on peut voir sur les
médias sociaux
non seulement ça mais aussi les titres
qui sont utilisés pour parler de cela
alors plutôt que de dire la communauté
de cannes s attaquer des sites de fermer
le parc d'oka pour diminuer
l'accès en temps de distanciation social
ducobu et bien on va lire les mots qu
ferme le port bloc par bloc le parc
d'oka
vous pouvez imaginer comment le poids de
ces deux titres peut avoir ce n'est pas
énorme sur comment les gens vont
commencer ensuite sur ces articles
donc les morts premièrement ils sont
trois communautés autour de montréal
laquelle communauté décident de bloquer
ce serait comme dire les blancs de sites
de bloquer quelque chose alors cédé fois
arrêté de faire ces généralisations là
pour expliquer que c'est un cas de
communauté et c'est un cas aussi de
désir de se garder en sécurité
présentement pourquoi est ce que les
mots qui sont plus stressés que disons
les québécois ou que les gens de la
communauté qui sont être heureux eux de
recevoir abreuvoir cette nouvelle manne
économique de tourisme faut pas oublier
qu'il ya quelques semaines seulement
la communauté de hockey avait été
approché par le maire d'oka ce conte à
la communauté et de 15,5 avec l'approché
par le maire d'oka pour les aider à
garder la route fermée
pour preuve pour pratiquer la
distanciation sociale il s'est rétracté
et maintenant il veut ouvrir la région
cependant la communauté elle continue
d'être sur ses gardes pour protéger sa
communauté et là on voit l'avènement de
d2 commentaires discriminatoires de
commentaires racistes et aussi des
commentaires très ignorant la
problématique c'est aussi le fait que
quand une maladie une pandémie peu
importe laquelle arrive historiquement
le support de la communauté canadienne
est très moindre par rapport aux
communautés autochtones que ce qu'on va
voir dans les villes ou dans l'est dans
les villages alors je donne comme
exemple 2009 le h1n1 on se rappelle que
cette époque lui certaines communautés
avait demandé de l'aide au gouvernement
pour pouvoir faire face à la crise du
h1n1 est plutôt que d'envoyer des
masques des gants du désinfectant à
l'époque qui n'était pas une denrée rare
non plus eh bien ils ont envoyé des body
bag c'est à dire des sacs pour les
cadors donc vous pouvez imaginer comment
les communautés de khon voit les
politiques de confinement comme étant
leurs responsabilités puisque personne
voit les appuyer de la même manière
qu'eux mêmes ou les communautés entre
elles
sir bien sûr ça change depuis quelques
années c'est extraordinaire mais on
s'entend que plus beau mieux
en sécurité qu'être désolé et une des
choses aussi qui nous inspire beaucoup à
garder ses politiques de confinement là
en place c'est nos aînés c'est une de
nos ressources les plus précieuses
puisqu'ils sont gardiens de la langue de
la culture son gardien de nos pratiques
traditionnelles et de notre histoire
eh bien nous ce que ce que j'entends ce
mois c'est qu'aucun décès d'aînés est
acceptable alors que dans certains
discours politiques discours qui est de
l'extérieur on entend que un certain
niveau de perte des nez est acceptable
donc un pourcentage qui est acceptable
ce qui devrait pas être le cas alors
vous comprendrez aussi que en plus on
doit rajouter la comparaison convoité
états unis où justement les communautés
les plus touchées dans tout le pays
américains ce sont les communautés
autochtones et même que certaines
communautés qui ont décidé d'appliquer
des politiques de fermeture de leurs
frontières
ce qui bloquent des routes entre les
états se voit menacé de réprimande et de
punitions sociale donc vous comprendrez
qu'à en tant que communauté autochtone
nous décidons de garder nos frontières
fermées par souci de sécurité
par souci aussi de l'impact que
certaines de ces maladies le 11 sur nos
communautés on est beaucoup plus
touchées beaucoup plus affectif la
communauté scientifique l'approuvent et
aussi on voit qu'avec les commentaires
avec la justification de pouvoir se
sentir libre de donner ses commentaires
là on ne sent pas qu'on a encore 100% de
l'est puis de notre communauté commune
donc en se gardant en sécurité on
garantit qu'on va passer à travers la
crise du club et de façon sécuritaire
mais malheureusement vous pouvez
imaginer comme niveau technique toute
situation en ce moment nous mais n'a pas
plus à fleur de peau alors imaginez
encore plus ces attaques racistes ou
discriminatoires qui peut avoir lieu ou
même se faire dire c'était ya 500 ans
passé par dessus ça veut dire que pour
nous c'est un signe
et une phrase qui indique vraiment que
non c'est aujourd'hui et ça va être
encore là demain donc vous comprendrez
qu'il faut absolument apportez votre
support votre compréhension ou
communautés qui décide de se garder
fermée qui décide d'appliquer leurs
droits ancestraux sur des territoires
pour se protéger du clos vide parce que
si elles ne le font pas qui va le faire
pour
alors je ferai une belle semaine
j'espère que vous vous y gagnerez en
santé et en sécurité et n'hésitez pas à
vous à nous envoyer des questions si
jamais vous en avez bonne semaine